Okay, so my understanding of it is that
because our society set
is set up like a patriarchy,
which means it is not set up to accommodate women,
mothers, and families,
is the reason why you had to make the choice
in the first place.
The world in which we live
that makes women work like they don't have kids
and have kids like they don't work
is a function of the patriarchy.
If we lived in a much more equitable society,
it would be assumed
that women could work and have children,
and the workforce would be
accommodating to that lifestyle change.
The fact that women are faced with such impossible
choices when having children and starting a family
is because we don't have Equality.
The choices we make seem so shitty
because it was set up that way.
Which is why
if it's financially feasible,
it does seem a lot
easier to stay home with your children.
Because that's the way our society
was set up in the first place,
for women to be home and men to be working.
And that's why,
as much as it, like,
sucks to say it,
that's why people come to my comments and tell me
staying home is not a feminist choice.